kids in my position are typically not
surrounded by motivating factors you
know environments that promote you know
inquiry diogenes placencia grew up in
the South Bronx in New York at one point
he and his mom lived with 20 other
people in a single room apartment four
do and many others the road to becoming
a scientist included many obstacles
beyond just getting a college education
let alone a PhD you grew up where I grew
up you're worried about survival you
know are you gonna make the rent next
month the food stamps coming in that
actually happened to us it was not a fun
time still there are many inspiring
stories of successful scientists who
came from humble beginnings today do is
a research chemist at the US Naval
Research Lab here at the lab I develop
materials for infrared cameras and
sensors basically to help out our
soldiers in the field to complete their
missions well the the type of work that
I do leads has led to all sorts of
things like OLED TVs quantum TVs I mean
everything from water filtration systems
to space applications I mean it's it's
everywhere knowing that you know the
soldiers that were helping our and maybe
and our Poorman sort of just have the
best technologies to accomplish their
mission that really means a lot to me
his interest in science peaked in high
school everything was going pretty well
and then I took chemistry it sounds like
one of those like and then I saw her
right chemistry basically spoke to me it
allowed me to understand how things work
do decided to pursue chemistry in
college getting a college education is
expensive for pretty much everybody but
the costs are especially hard on lower
income students I got some scholarships
but I still needed to come up with quite
a bit of money
now we're talking maybe 15 grand
you know out of pocket for somebody you
know my mom didn't have a savings
account and I think that's where that
sort of pressure to perform came because
I knew that that's that's something that
was waiting for me at the end of all of
that do says that mentors were a huge
factor in helping him become a scientist
I mean I can't overstate how important
it has been to have somebody there to
sort of guide you along the way if
adults are listening to this I think
that they have to try to be as
encouraging of that inquiry mindset
that's key because if they don't hear
the encouragement saying hey you know
you should really think about this or
yeah that's great you know just
positivity because you're surrounded by
so much negativity deal also said that
coming from a disadvantaged background
gave him the grit and determination that
drove him throughout his career we say
the Spanish his word and Spanish supa
Dada you know to to overcome you know if
you have that desire to overcome
whatever situation that you're in you'll
be fine and just keep your head down
work as hard as you can and you just
grind that's it
[Music]
you
[Music]